Hello,
and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
I am your host, David Flanagan.
Although, hopefully, you know me from across the
Internet as Rawkode.
Today, we're taking a look at another open
source project. This one is Kamaji.
It's going to simplify
your Kubernetes control plane life.
We're gonna dive into that in much more
detail in just a moment. But first, I
wanna introduce our guest who's gonna guide us
through the Kamaji journey,
Daniel.
Hello, Daniel. How are you? Hey. Everything is
fine. Hope the same for you. Nice to
meet you all.
Thank you very much. Yeah. I'm doing good.
I'm always excited to take a look at
a new
open source tool, especially within the Kubernetes space.
I like playing with Kubernetes, and I like
my Kubernetes to be easier.
And I I'm pretty sure you're gonna show
me some really cool things today to make
my life happier and better. And if I
get more sleep, I'm a happy man. And
we've already had a comment in the chat
from engine
who is very curious about the claim with
a fraction of the operational burden.
So, yes, we are going to make your
Kubernetes lives easier today. But before we do
that, can you please tell us a little
bit about about yourself, please? Sure. Sure. Absolutely.
So my name is Dario. The surname is,
but I know that it's really hard, especially
because
from abroad, it's really hard to pronounce in
the correct pronunciation in Italian.
And I'm based in the North Of Italy
near Turin, and I'm software engineer. I fell
in love with containers
since a sizable amount of years. Honestly, I
don't remember.
And I was a developer, a web developer,
and I faced the issue to scale my
applications across the cloud and to the Infinite
and beyond.
And I fell in love with Docker and
then OpenShift.
I use also MesoFacebook.c0s,
and it was really
a tough job. And then I started working
on Kubernetes.
I started working
in a cloud provider,
and I was responsible for the cyber liability
engineering stuff. And I started developing operators, controller
times. And I had the time to starting
the code base and especially trying to combine
my software skills, my software development skills with
the systems.
And starting from 2020,
I joined Classics as a technical adviser,
and I'm doing
the technical stuff. So I write software.
I do demos and so on and so
forth, and it's really fun. I'm enjoying this
job.
Awesome.
So this is the the first Kubernetes
open source project from Clastics. Right? You also
helped maintain Captule, I believe? Yeah. Yeah. It's
the second one. We started with Captule because
we noticed that there is a missing gap
in Kubernetes ecosystem, especially regarding the multi tenancy.
So instead of spawning several Kubernetes clusters,
you can use just a single one, and
you can isolate the namespaces into a tenant
abstraction. So the tenant abstraction is pretty common
because
when you got multiple namespaces, you're ending up
grouping them into this abstraction.
It's a layer that is a collection of
namespaces. But sometimes you have to spin up
multiple clusters for various reasons, maybe because you
would like to avoid at all the
noise enabler effects, or you would like to
use different API versions, different Kubernetes clusters, and
so forth. So we started thinking, how to
address the real hard multi tenancy because casual
is addressing the soft one. So just name
spaces. But I would like to bring my
real own nodes and having a real control
plane that I can use. So I can
toggle
dynamic admission controllers. I can fine tune parameters
and so on and so forth. And
this drove us in drafting Kamaji that I'm
going to present today.
Yeah. You seem to be quite fond of
solving the hard problems with Kubernetes, like multitenancy
and control plane commoditization.
Like Yeah. Yeah. I guess as if you
just woken up about how can I make
my life a little harder today, but at
the same time, help everyone else? So I
I really appreciate that you are working on
these hard problems because
multitenancy is hard and
yeah. But it's it's good that there's
much more sophisticated and better tooling coming out
to kinda help people with that.
Yeah. Totally. Totally agree.
So with that being said, why don't you
kinda touched on it there about what Kamaji
is, but do you wanna give us a
slightly longer description? What what is Kamaji for,
and what problems does it solve for people?
Well, you know,
I started using Kubernetes starting from
02/2016.
And at the time, I don't remember, but
I'm pretty sure that there was a huge
bash script that was used to install a
Kubernetes cluster.
It was create cluster or something like that,
and it was a pain to manage that.
I remember that all the people that I
was meeting in Italy, they were using Kubernetes,
but using the managed services by GKE,
so by Google Cloud Platform
or by Azure.
So
it was really hard to set up a
Kubernetes cluster, but the community addresses that
problem and started developing nice projects. And the
most satisfying one is obviously KubeAdam,
because with KubeAdam,
we can
configure the worker nodes, the control plane. So
we got all the building
blocks to create
a full fledged installation of cluster of a
Kubernetes cluster.
And after that, we ended up also with
cluster API, and it's really great because in
the end, it's a sort
it's not a wrapper. Sorry if I'm saying
something that is not entirely correct, but it's
wrapping around kubeadm,
although you can specify
different
bootstrap options.
But with cluster API, you're ending up spawning
multiple clusters.
And with that said, I noticed that a
lot of people, instead of trying to solve
the multi tenancy issue in the Kubernetes ecosystem,
they start spawning multiple clusters.
And the first one, the second one, the
third one, and you're ending up with dozen
or thousand or hundred of clusters according to
your dimension of your company and so on
and so forth. And I've been there because
I was working for this cloud provider.
And I remember that
the size
was
bit impressive to me at that time because
I was managing five production clusters
on bare metal,
and the overall amount
of virtual machines was
2,500
nodes, virtual machines, but on bare metal. So
you can understand that I was getting pager
duty during the night, and I didn't enjoy
that job, honestly, so much because it was
really cumbersome to manage. You know, we are
ending up saying, okay. You can manage Kubernetes
scale. You can have multiple cluster,
and you can do everything
so perfect, but you're ending up obviously with
some side effects. So although you're trying to
automate everything,
you are ending up with some alerts or
some tasks to perform
according to the timing. So rotate certificates
or eventually
controlling the notice of duration and so on
and so forth. And at that time, I
was developing a lot of operators, a lot
of custom controllers,
and I then end up saying,
we got operators.
Operators are
translating the human knowledge,
the operator,
the human operator knowledge into code.
And in the end, I'm doing a lot
of repetitive task,
taking care of a Kubernetes cluster. So why
cannot create an operator
that is taking care of all these activities?
I was thinking about this project for a
long time, then I joined Classics.
I was on the same line with Adriano,
my business partner.
And with that said, we decided to start
developing Kamaji.
And right now, we got
this it's not a proof of concept because
it's working,
and we got customers that are already using
that. We are really happy for that.
And, yeah,
that's the reason why I'm here. I started
with multitenancy, and now I'm doing
deep Kubernetes stuff, the cube inception. You know?
Nice.
Yeah. I mean, you said that, you know,
you've you've done bare metal Kubernetes, and that's
something that I'm really passionate about as well.
I I like to run my Kubernetes as
close to the metal as possible, but I
think the pattern that that I've seen, I'm
sure you've seen it too,
we're seeing loads of other projects kind of
follows it here, is that for the worker
pool, yes, you want to be running on
the metal. But the control plane, you probably
wanna virtualize it. Like,
control planes aren't really doing a lot of
heavy lifting. They're really just right into entity
and answer some API request. And to run
them on metal is usually a waste of
CPU memory.
And plus, we need to be able to
handle the upgrade path for these control player
nodes in a pretty safe manner, and
bare metal is very, very, very slow to
reboot.
So that brings a whole bunch of other
challenges to it. And I think this is
why we're seeing this virtualization
of the control plane become,
a more popular pattern.
Then with an interesting one I've seen recently
was, you know, we've worked for pushing firecracker
for the control plane, but then bare metal
worker nodes. And I think Kamaji really comes
into this space as well and is that,
yeah, like, we can virtualize this and then
run all your work bring your own worker
pool bare metal or not. And I think
this pattern will become even more prominent as
time kinda progresses.
Yeah. Yeah. Absolutely. Anyway, I would like also
to thank you because
while we were talking about Kamaji,
I told you about the cube inception, and
you used this term, the Kubeception.
And I tried to create
a set of slides about these topics of
the Kubeception. I hope that you enjoy my
memes because I really love
crafting memes about Kubernetes.
Yeah. I thought that Kubeception was a really
was a really good kind of prominent capture
word play on what we're gonna be looking
at today. I I I really wanted that
to be there. And in fact, we have
a comment from Russell on the chat as
well.
So is this Kubernetes inception, many Kubernetes clusters,
and say the one Kubernetes cluster?
Kind of. I think we'll see in just
a minute. I'm gonna let Adi present some
slides, and we'll take it from there.
Engine does ask a question as well. I
don't know if you wanna tackle it now
or wait till after your slides, but he
says, is this similar to SAP
Gardener in a way to handle the control
plane?
Yeah. It's pretty similar, but we will show
you. I don't want to spoil the plot.
Alright.
Well, you are sharing your screen, so I'm
gonna pop over there.
Feel free to take it away. And if
I have any questions, I'll throw them at
you as we go.
Sure. Sure. Great. Thank you so much. So
welcome here, and I would like to present
you Kamaji.
And as David said, this is the exception
because we are doing something really weird,
at least
according to the majority of people.
But I would like to start from the
beginning because I've been a developer.
I've been on the other side, and I
was
one of the people asking, would like to
use Kubernetes.
But I don't want to mention that.
And right now, in 2022,
a lot of people is using Kubernetes. I
say
most of the companies around the world are
using Kubernetes because
it's used to create your software and service
solutions.
It's used by AI, machine learning, or analytics
applications.
And also on the edge, next to the
Internet of Things.
And as I said, I've been there.
I can say that's shameless.
Sometimes we feel
the burden of the complexity of Kubernetes. So
we would like to offload everything
to managed providers,
or if we can, also to the infrastructure
team if we if we have an organization
like that.
So why we need that? Because in the
end, we are developers. We would like to
focus on the applications, and we don't want
to manage a Kubernetes cluster. I don't know.
Maybe there is people
around the world that are excited to get
pages during the night. I wasn't, so I
would like to get something that is solving
all the problems.
So this is the reason why I started
developing Kamaji.
And what are the challenges? Because with Kamaji,
we are aiming to build a sort of
building block. It's not a product.
I'd say it's
just one of the tools
to create multiple Kubernetes clusters.
And there is a huge lack of tools,
especially in the open source.
We know that there are some players that
are already providing multicluster management.
For example, there is
OCP, OpenShift Container Platform, by Red Hat. There
is also SUSI that
acquired Ranger a few years ago. We got
also VMware Tanzu.
And they're absolutely great developer experience on top
of that. It's absolutely mesmerizing because I also
work with OpenShift Container Platform.
And for developers, it's great.
But there is a there are some downsides,
I'd say, because all these tools
are designed for enterprises.
So it means that
you have to stick to their way of
doing stuff.
And besides that, there is also a high
total cost of ownership. You got licenses. You
got operations. It's not straightforward.
I say it's not real Kubernetes because in
the end, are using Ranger. You're using Tanzu.
You're using OpenShift, and all these solutions
are built on top of Kubernetes.
Although,
pretty sure that the API server is the
same, but I hope that you're getting the
point. It's not clear Kubernetes.
It's a opinionated
way of managing Kubernetes.
And last but not least,
all these solutions
are pushing
on the
way to manage your clusters
by spinning up multiple clusters.
So you're ending up, or you could end
up, in the cluster sprawl.
And what's the cluster sprawl? It's a nice
term that has been
inherited by the
city sprawl, by
the sprawl of neighbors
when the city, when a city,
is growing a lot.
And this is the first reference to inception
because this is the cluster sprawl because we
are in the gap with a lot of
clusters,
a lot of skyscrapers,
a lot of houses, and so on and
so forth. So it's really hard to maintain.
I've been there, as I told you before,
just few clusters,
but it was really cumbersome. And you can
imagine what it could be
with huge organizations
where you have to manage and keep care
of multiple clusters.
Anyway,
there is another meme. And
why we started this project?
Because
I love complex stuff, to be honest, especially
when you have to write when you have
to write code for complex stuff.
And I remember the first time that I
saw Docker in Docker, user used by GitLab.
And it was really interesting because you're ending
up with Docker inside a Docker container, and
you can do a lot of stuff.
Essentially, GitLab pipelines
is built on top of that.
And then suddenly, I discovered the operators that
are really great because
in the end,
you are floating all the
SIL task
to a software, to a binary. This is
running inside the cluster.
And
it's a binary. It's a software.
It doesn't have bugs. Well, I'm just joking.
But, you know, you can do whatever you
want and focusing on your infrastructure or your
code and so on and so forth. And
then I saw also, I'd say together,
the database on Kubernetes,
the rise of databases on Kubernetes. And I
remember that a lot of people were saying,
no, no, no. We cannot use databases on
Kubernetes. It's too much complicated. We can not
we can we can't do that.
And in the end, we saw a lot
of vendors starting developing operators,
starting offering
database as a service backed by Kubernetes itself.
So it means that it could be done.
And lastly,
I ended up also with Kind that is
Kubernetes in Docker. So it's inception inside inception.
So we are ending up with a Docker
container that is a Kubernetes cluster that you
can use
for testing, for CI, for development. For example,
I'm using Kind a lot for the development.
So it's 2022,
and we can do that. But while I
was thinking about that, I started asking myself,
I cannot really do that because we know
that in the end, Kubernetes cluster is pretty
complex. I'd say we got a lot of
components,
a lot of business logic. I mean, it's
not like a classic web page where you
got the database,
you got the front end, you got the
back end, end of the story.
But with Kubernetes, obviously, we got a lot
of components involved. We got the certificate authority.
We got certificates
management.
We got the back end storage, and so
on and so forth. So
I started asking myself, how can I do
that?
And
I started trying
to define the pillars of Kamaji
because our idea is saying, okay, we got
applications that are running in Kubernetes
that got a back end storage.
In the end, Kubernetes
is made of several components.
I'd say the first one is the stateless
one, because we got the API server that
is connecting
to AdCity.
Then we got the controller manager and the
scheduler that are connecting using the kube config
for their own component using the API server.
So API server is absolutely stateless. All the
state is stored in ad cd.
So the idea was to say,
let's try to move the multitenancy
from the infrastructure level, so from the virtual
machines,
to the containers,
as we are doing with the applications.
But multi tenancy must be moved into the
data store.
So you know all that. Etcd is the
key value store that we are using for
Kubernetes.
And starting from version
3.5,
it has been introduced a new feature that
is named the add cd namespaces,
and too long didn't rent. It's a sort
of schema of the databases. So in MySQL
or PostgreSQL
or whatever
database you would like to use, you got
the schemes,
and essentially it's the same stuff. So in
the etcd,
you know, to be honest, you're ending up
just with a prefix of the keys, but
you can use certificates,
user roles, just to segregate this data, and
you're ending up with namespaces
like the ones of Kubernetes.
And after that,
as I told you all before, it's kube
inception kubeception because in the end, we are
using Kubernetes to manage Kubernetes itself.
So our Kamaji is orchestrating
the pods that will be the virtual control
plane
and it's going to manage also the shared
data store.
But I guess that also a picture is
more worth than a thousand of words.
So here it is, the architecture,
and I'll try to describe it
in the best way possible.
So Kamaji
needs a Kubernetes cluster,
because otherwise that will be a next chicken
problem. Because we have to manage multiple clusters,
but we need a cluster. So the cluster
must be created in advance. It means that
we need an admin cluster,
something that will be named a management cluster.
And this could be any Kubernetes compliant cluster.
It could be whatever version you will like.
For our demo, we are going to use
one
twenty one or one twenty two. I don't
remember.
We're in this cluster.
And inside this cluster, I we are going
to install also Kamaji
through an Elm chart,
and this Elm chart is installing the CRDs.
We got the Tenant Control Plane CRD
that will spawn these pods that are the
virtual
control planes.
But how
these pods are connecting to the AdCity?
Obviously, we got a multi tenant AdCity that,
for the sake of simplicity, has been deployed
inside the admin cluster,
but it could be also outside of your
cluster. It's not a prerequisite. It's up to
you to manage etcd.
We developed the ham chart, and the ham
chart is taking care of setting up the
etcd, enabling the feature for the multi tenancy,
generating the certificates, and so on and so
forth.
So
with that said, when we are creating a
tenant control plane using Kamaji, we are ending
up with a pod. And this pod is
exposed using a node port,
an ingress, exposed using a load balancer service.
And obviously,
those pods
are a cluster,
but they are missing the nodes. Because Kamaji
is not using
the nodes of the admin cluster,
but is exposing
all the,
I would say that, the endpoints, all the
information required to perform the bootstrap
of nodes to join that cluster.
So in the end, we are ending up
with the definition of the tenant node pools.
So it means that
these are worker nodes,
and they could be also containers. They could
be Firecracker virtual machines. They could be virtual
machines or bare metal instances.
They just need to join the cluster using
kubeadm.
And another
meme, because I'm really in love with meme,
because you can understand there are so many
components that are moving together. Because
when we are dealing with the API server,
we need certificates,
we need the kube config, we need the
config map with the kube adm configuration.
There is also a spoiler alert down there.
We got also connectivity.
So Kamaji
is trying to
simplify the management of all these
silly task
in an automated way.
So I'd say that
the next the next step is starting the
demo time. And, obviously, I have to summon
the demo god because I tried several times
the demo. It's working, but, you know, it's
also Murphy's Law, so fingers crossed.
Yeah. Now that we're all looking at a
whole different ballgame. But we do have a
question on the chat if you're happy to
answer that just before you jump into the
demo. Sure. Sure. So Russell says,
is the admin cluster etcd also the etcd
used by each tenant cluster, or do we
need separate ones?
Yeah. I'd say that, you know,
it really depends.
But, honestly, I would avoid the single point
of failure because in the end, what happens
if you
break the ad cd using Kamaji or something
like that. So
you can do that. You can use the
same
ad cd, but honestly, I will avoid that
just to be sure to decrease
the point of failures. So having add cd
for the tenant clusters
will be much better. So you're decoupling from
the admin cluster one. Okay. You know, you're
you're not putting all the eggs in the
same
how to say that?
Basket. Basket.
Yeah. Sorry. Yeah. I was speaking Italian. You
know? So
yeah. So I was just gonna
continue with that a little bit. So you
can have one entity cluster.
And using entity namespaces.
You can have the admin cluster, one namespace,
and all the tenants on another. But in
production,
you probably want one entity for
the admin cluster and then one entity shared
amongst your tenant. Is that what you would
kind of promote?
Yeah. Yeah. Absolutely. Also, keep in mind that
I don't want to spoil it, but I
will I haven't used
entity in production. But I don't want to
spoil that, like, because it's really interesting. I'll
show you later.
Okay.
Anyway Yeah. Carry on. Carry on. On. Carry
on.
Keep in mind that
we need Kubernetes cluster.
So what I did is to install
well, not install it, but creating Kubernetes cluster
on AKS.
So I'm on Azure
cluster info,
as you can see here. So we create
a Kamaji
in the zone
of AKS. It was West Europe.
And
this management cluster, this admin cluster, as you
can see, is 1221,
will,
get installed with Kamaji.
So how can I install Kamaji? It's pretty
straightforward because I have to use Helm upgrade
install.
I don't remember the order
of the arguments,
but I got my history with me. So
I'm installing Kamaji
from the chart that I got
in my local directory, so Ham Kamaji,
in the namespace Kamaji system, and creating the
namespace.
That's great.
And now in the other pane, I'm going
to watch
all the pods that are going to be
created. So using KubeNS, I am switching the
namespace in Kamaji system
and performing with my beloved aliases.
Kubectl get pods minus w.
So I am watching the pods.
When you're installing Kamaji,
by default,
you're getting up with a net CD
in and
we are taking care of generating certificates,
enabling all the features, and so on and
so forth. So right now we have to
wait a few minutes, I'd say,
for the free replicas,
and we should end up with everything installed.
Yeah. So in the end, as you can
see here,
we got etcd, free replicas, and Kamaji.
And we got also our CRD
deployed,
and it's the tenant control planes Kamaji
Classics IO.
And also,
our operator has been deployed, and I can
check the logs using kubectl logs minus n
Kamaji
system.
I don't remember. So, yeah, I go to
this three. I love this three. Minus l,
Kubernetes IO component controller manager, minus c manager
follow.
Just to be sure that the controller is
up and running, is watching all the events,
and is starting
the workers.
That's great. And now what we have is
to deploy
a manifest of the talent control plane.
So I am entering in classics,
Kamaji,
And for this demo,
I already have a sample
that I'm showing with you. So
this is the API definition of the CRD,
and the name is Rawkode.
Keep in mind that all these resources of
the tenant control plane, since our spawning
pod
secrets, config map,
services, and so on and so forth,
are names is is a namespace scope resource.
So we can specify the namespace to default.
And we can define
also
various options. So we can define the options
for the control plane and managing the deployment,
the service, and also the ingress.
Well, with the ingress, it's really hard because
Kubernetes has not been designed to use to
get exposed using an ingress.
So you are not barely using fully qualified
domain names. Just for the sake of simplicity,
I'm going to use a load balancer.
So AKS
well, Azure is going to deploy a service
of load balancer type and giving me an
API, a public and routable IP
address. Not API, IP address.
Then I'm defining also the deployments up to
two replicas. And why two replicas? Because in
the end, if you think about that, we
are just managing the API server, control manager,
and the scheduler because all the state would
be managed by etcd.
And now here comes the really important stuff
because we can define all the information regarding
all the information regarding Kubernetes. So I'm saying
I would like to deploy one, two, two,
three, And I can set also a configuration
for the cubelet, for the nodes that are
going to join my new cluster.
I'm going to say that I would like
to use the cgroupfs
systemd,
defining some admission controllers,
and I can say also
extra parameters,
extra arcs for all the components of the
control plane. So if you would like to
enable
some specific
cloud integrations or specific flags, you can do
that. So we don't have to create a
mapping
with all the possible informations,
all all possible settings of the API server,
the scheduler, and so on and so forth.
Just the most important ones. Okay. I'm just
gonna interject very quickly, just because you answered
a question there. So engine did ask in
the comment. Can we set feature flags? So
the answer is, as you asked, using the
extra Yeah. Yeah. The extra. Yeah. Absolutely. Absolutely.
Because otherwise,
it will be really hard to follow everything.
And
then we got also network profile, And network
profile is really interesting because we can set
the address if we already know the address,
or otherwise, we can set the port that
we are expecting
to get connections.
This example, we are going to use the
sixty four forty
three, the default one. So I am going
to get my load balancer with my public
IP, and it will be the internal control
plane will be
reachable using that IP on this port.
And then I got also the add ons.
So if you are familiar with kubeadm, obviously,
we are following
the same structure. So with kubeadm
in it,
I don't remember, but pretty sure just need
to read the docs.
There is the add ons, so you can
configure the core DNS and kubeproxy.
It's optional, kubeproxy, because if you would like
to use, I don't know, maybe Cilium,
I don't want to use kubeproxy, you can
do that.
For information.
Sure. Sure. So can you
can we specify our own CNI here, or
are we bound by by admin cluster?
No. No. It's up to the admin cluster.
Oh, yeah. Okay. Cool. That's what I Not
the admin cluster, but I'd say the
10 the cluster owner,
so who's going to use Rawkode.
In this case, I can show also the
cube copy to you so you can type
from your local machine interacting with the cluster
if you want. Will be great. Yeah. I
wasn't I wasn't thinking about that. I'm going
to share with you also configs,
you're interacting with the cluster.
Anyway, yeah,
we had a discussion internal and classics if
we will like to provide also installation of
the CNI,
but we try to stick to the
to the
convention of kubeadm and cluster API. So when
you're spinning up a cluster using q
a cluster using cluster API,
the CNI must be installed
after
Yeah. The extra provision. Yeah. Because I could
use
different CNI for each cluster. So
we don't want to be opinionated,
but we can talk about that. Don't worry.
We are looking for feedback.
So this is our definition. That's great.
So what I would like to do now
is to apply that.
So just to be sure
oh,
it's Friday also for me.
When as default,
kubectl apply minus f config
samples,
Kamaji v one alpha one, then a control
plane.
And I'll open also
another tab
watching for kubectl
get tenant control plane. Yeah. The short name
is pretty
misleading,
TCP,
but, you know, we
we do love
doing jokes. So TCP is standalone control plane.
So now I can create create it. Fingers
crossed.
I'll watch again for the logs.
And as you can see here,
the logs are polluting us, saying, I I
don't have an address.
We have to wait for the address. In
fact, as you can see here now,
in the get TCP, in the watch, we
are ending up with a control plane endpoint.
So this is the routable IP that we
are going to use
for
connecting to the cluster using this port,
using this kube config,
and the status saying that it's in provisioning
state. And in a matter of seconds, I'd
say,
yeah, just now, after forty five seconds, we
got a cluster that is ready.
In fact, if I try to issue Carl
minus k,
this control plane endpoint,
we are getting our cluster. Right.
But, obviously, I cannot use Carl.
If I would like to interact with the
Kubernetes cluster, I would like to use a
kubeconfig.
That's fair. In fact, Kamaji is also generating
the
admin kubeconfig
that is stored
in a secret named Rawkode
admin kubeconfig.
Rawkode is the name of my tenant control
plane.
So what I have to do is to
search on my history,
and kubectl
gets secret Rawkode admin q config, output JSON,
j q minus r
data admin config, base 64 decoding,
and piping to TMP Rawkode,
which will write a bash code or a
plug in to do that because
it's pretty cumbersome. I always use the history.
Okay. We got our kube config.
I'll show you
just
for the sake
of sharing.
And as you can see here, we got
our certificate authority data. We got our server,
our context,
and, obviously, also the certificate to interact with
the class.
With that said,
I just need to override the kube config
config
to TMP
Rawkode
Rawkode,
kubectl
version.
And as you can see here, we got
our CLASA because it's 01/23,
and it's the same version that we saw
in the tenant control plane definition.
So '1 '20 '3 and '1 '20 '3.
If I try to issue again
kubectl
get nodes,
obviously,
we don't have any node.
Why this? Because we just provisioned the control
plane.
And we will like to use Kamaji
just for the control plane pods, the virtualized
control plane, because the nodes
will be in another region.
And for this demo, I'd
say that the nodes are not on AKS,
well, are not on Azure, but rather they
are on
AWS.
So with that said,
I already prepared also on AWS
a launch template.
This launch template
is using Cloud Init to
install all the root power components. Let me
check because I'm not so much familiar with
AWS,
especially using the UI. Yeah. As you can
see here, we got the cloud config, the
Cloud Init configuration. So we are installing containerd,
car,
performing all the well, all the
obvious task that we have to do to
set up
Kubernetes cluster. So installing the kubelet, kubeadm,
containerd, and so on and so forth.
Okay?
And we should have also the configuration for
containerd.
I'm a bit worried because I see that
it's missing a parameter, but ah, yeah. Because
I have to use the latest version.
Yeah.
We have to use the system DC group
driver because otherwise we will end up with
some issues.
Anyway,
from this launch template,
I would like to create some set of
nodes. And these nodes that are on AWS
will join the virtual control plane deployed by
Kamaji
that is deployed
on Azure.
So
Rawkode
worker nodes,
I'm going to use,
the template description. No. I don't want that.
Auto scaling guidance, no.
Template tags, source template.
I would like to use this one with
the latest version.
I don't I don't need to use the
oh, my bad. Sorry.
I don't have to create a launch template,
but I have to start
note screening group from this template.
My bad. So
Rawkode
oh, Kamaji
worker nodes
using my launch template,
the latest version.
That's great. We are going to spin up
t free medium machines.
I'm saying in my VPC,
all of these,
t free medium, it's okay. Let's go for
next. No load balancer. No monitoring. Not at
all. We just need some
machines.
So desired capacity, let's start with one. Maximum
capacity,
10.
And now
I'm going to
create
everything.
Okay.
VPC settings, create auto screening groups.
And in the meanwhile,
I'm going to share with you, David,
the file
of the kube config.
And I think that I can use the
commands.
I'll share with you
via email, if you don't mind. Okay? Yeah.
Yeah. Sure. Go for it.
In the meanwhile, we can wait for
the node to get provision.
Yep. Can I ask a couple of questions
as well? Absolutely. Absolutely. Yeah. So you haven't
specified the KubeConfig for the worker nodes. Are
we gonna be doing that interactively?
No.
No. No. There are some default values. We
are using just the default values for the
sake of simplicity. Okay.
And see if the control plane
containers,
like I mean, that was pretty fast. Like,
thirty seconds, and we had a control plane.
Are those images that you're building and publishing?
Are those being
like, how do you The images were already
cached, so
it really depends also because I already tested
that
before
the video stream. But, yeah, you have to
think also about the pooling
of the container images. But But what images
are told? What imagery are you using for
the Absolutely. I can show you that. So
let's edit the Rawkode deployment
so we can also take a look to
the internals of Kamaji.
So, obviously, we got the owner reference control
well, we got the owner reference to the
time control plane resource that is used for
the operator pattern,
and then we got our containers.
And in the containers,
we are defining all the arguments for the
API server.
So we are defining the etcd servers.
And as you can see here, we can
define also the etcd prefix.
So this is the namespace that we are
going to use in the multi term etcd.
And then we got the etcd key file
and blah blah blah, all the informations.
Then we got also
the following one
that is going to be
Schedula.
And as you can see here, we are
using the k eight s VCR IO images.
Yeah. These are just the standard upstream This
is one. Control plane images. Perfect. Alright. Cool.
Absolutely.
And also for for the controller manager.
Obviously, are wanting all the certificates,
the CA, and so on and so forth
because all the communication, although, is living inside
all the components are inside the same pod.
We were thinking about
ending up with multiple deployments.
So as you can see here, we got
a deployment,
two replicas,
and three containers.
And the reason for that is that
in the end,
we would like to use the loopback interface
for faster connection
between the controller manager and the scheduler.
So in the end, we don't need a
leader election.
We don't need to scale differently the controller
manager or the scheduler.
Or we could potentially
have that need,
but we are open for discussion for that.
Keep in mind that it's an open source
project, so the governance
must be managed by the community. So we
are really hoping to get your point, your
feedback about that.
From the beginning, it was much easier
using a single container well, a single pod
with multiple containers.
So let's see also what the community think
about that.
Anyway,
we should have now,
fingers crossed,
our instances.
Yeah. We got our instance.
Now I'm connecting to it
just to be sure that everything has been
configured properly.
So
Ubuntu,
that machine,
and let me check
if Cloud init has been completed or not.
I'd say so because we got kubelet, kubeadm,
kubectl,
and just to be sure,
I like to play safe
container d config tamag.
Oh,
it's not my laptop. Okay.
System d c group true.
That's perfect. Okay.
So now that we got our node,
what we have to do?
Well, obviously,
we have to extract the token for QADM
to let,
to let the node
join the cluster.
So with that said, I export the kube
config to Rawkode.
We don't have any node,
and what I have to issue is kube
ADM
token create
print join command.
So
in the end, it means that we are
going to use the exposed
IP
address on the port with this token, with
this discovery token CA cert
hash that is used for the CA.
So with that said,
in the
pane that is SSHed
to the node, I am passing the command
and adding b three
just because
the guard has been really good for to
me. Everything is working, but, you know, I
just want to be sure.
And in the meanwhile,
I'm going to look at
two nodes
and pods.
Obviously, keep in mind that we don't have
any node,
and obviously we've got Kubernetes,
Kube proxy that has not been deployed.
It's not a big problem. So now in
the node, in the AWS node,
I'll issue kubectm join, and the node will
join
the
virtual control plane that is deployed on AKS.
We just need to wait for the TLS
bootstrap,
but here it is.
As you can see here, we got our
node,
100.280.98,
1 0 0 2 8 9 8, and
we got our kube proxy, our cover DNS,
and so on and so forth. But, obviously,
there is something that is not working because
the node is not is
is not ready.
So what we have to do is to
export again our Rawkode
and apply the manifest
of Calico.
At CNI, you can solve whatever you want.
It was working for me with Calico, so
don't want to test with another one because
everything is so perfect right now, so I
don't want to waste everything.
So installing Calico,
it has been installed.
And as you can see here, we are
ending up with the
Calico node that will install all the CAE
and all the binaries and configurations.
And our node should be marked as ready
in a matter of seconds,
or at least I hope so.
Yeah, you know, that's been marketed as ready.
So we are ending up with CoreDNS.
We are ending up with Kalicoke, KubeControllers,
and all the containers that we are going
to deploy inside of our cluster.
So just to recap,
we got Kamaji
installed
in a Kubernetes cluster also on Azure.
This control plane is exposed using a load
balancer.
The pods are on Azure,
and the nodes
are
joining using the nodes are joining from AWS.
So
you can
use whatever you want. You can do that
on bare metal. You can do on your
even even on your virtual machines using KVM,
virtual machines, or Firecracker VMs, whatever you want.
And that's great because in the end, it's
I'd say obviously, I'm I'm saying that's shameless
because this is a project I work to
I work and contribute to. But getting point,
you can use Kamaji
to create as a building block
for
a truly managed Kubernetes service. You can imagine
maybe a portal,
an application,
where you're telling your developers,
click here to create your Kubernetes cluster.
Give me your credentials for the AWS
account
so you are accountable for the cost of
the control of the worker nodes.
I'll send you the kube config and so
on and so forth. I will install everything
on your behalf.
So in the end,
it's a sort of framework
to build whatever you want.
But now,
there is something that is not working,
and it's the following one. So everything is
working. So I'm really happy for that. We
don't have pods that are in restart mode.
But
let's imagine I would like to take a
look
to the kube proxy logs.
Obviously, I can do that from the machine.
Try CTL ps.
Try CTL where is? Kube proxy. It's the
latest it's the last one. Try CTL
logs minus f.
So everything is fine,
but
I don't have access to that machine because
that machine has been installed
by the developer.
I have the credentials, obviously, but
I will try to extract them,
connect
to the AWS, and blah blah blah. It's
a pain. Also, maybe I couldn't have also
the SSH key to connect to the node.
So as an administrator of the cluster,
I could say, kubectl
minus n, kubectl, log,
minus f,
kubectl,
it's not working.
Why?
Because
the node is IP 1002898,
and it's trying to connect to the cubelet
port.
And here comes the troubles,
because obviously,
if you think about that, Kamaji is on
AKS,
is on the Azure network,
and the worker nodes are on AWS.
Obviously, I can say
all the worker nodes must be must have
a routable public IP. I'm letting join the
nodes using their public IP,
but that will be recumbersome also because it
means that from the security perspective and also
from the security assessment, you can imagine, for
bigger organization, it will be terrible, I say.
You have to open the ports, all the
firewall,
the WAF, and so on and so forth.
So it's not manageable.
Okay?
We noticed that.
So there is a nice feature
that I would like to show you.
And
let me unset the kubeconfig,
and I'm going to change
the definition
of the tenant control plane.
As you remember, we got the add ons.
And with add ons, we can configure coordinates
and kube proxy.
But there is also
another component,
I'd say an add on that unfortunately is
not managed by kubeadm,
and I'm saying that because trying to wire
everything in Kamaji has been a pain due
to that, and it's connectivity.
Connectivity,
I'll try to say that using the terms
from the documentation.
It's a
reverse proxy for the control plane communications to
the worker nodes and vice versa, or vice
versa.
But I prefer to say that it's
a reverse exploit tunnel.
Because in the end,
what's going to happen is that we are
ending up with two components.
The connectivity server
that is on the control plane, so on
Kamaji,
and the connectivity agent.
So the connectivity agent
is launched
as a pod inside the worker nodes. The
worker nodes, obviously,
they can connect to the Kamaji
tenant control plane.
They establish a connection, and using this connection,
they are starting a
bidirectional communication from the cubelet to the API
server and
vice versa. So
with that said, I also just set the
connectivity port,
or rather the proxy port.
And I'm going to say eighty one forty
two.
That's great.
Now what I would like to do is
to create another tab,
and I will show you with watch
minus n heap CTL get
pods
secrets
service.
Maybe this one. Yeah.
What's going to happen?
So
I can enter
the path where I got my
manifest,
Kamaji,
apply my Nuxt config,
samples,
and a control plane.
And here comes the pane.
Because as you can see here now, we
got a new certificate. That's the connectivity certificate.
And we are spinning up a new deployment.
It means a new pod.
Why that? Because
we need
to get the proxy agent.
Well, the proxy server
sitting
beside the API server,
because the API server
is aware that there is the
connectivity
server
that will be
the tunnel
to communicate with the worker nodes.
So let's wait now
for the reconciliation.
But as you can see also from the
logs, we got Rawkode, so our instance of
the time control plane has been reconciled.
So
if we take a look here, we got
our service Rawkode,
our load balancer on Azure
with this IP,
and now we got also 8142.
So the connectivity port, so far so good.
So now we can switch again
on our tenant control plane.
Well, yeah, on our tenant cluster.
And as you can see here, now we
got a new port.
Well, it's not a port, it's a demo
set.
And it's connectivity
agent that has been spin up eighty seconds
ago.
And
since I know
that things can go wrong, I just want
to be sure that the connectivity
the connectivity, yeah, of the load balancer is
good enough. So let me check from the
logs.
Price CTL
logs minus f is one.
Yeah. Start serving.
So with that said, remember
that the AWS node has been announced using
a non routable IP,
so the API server cannot connect
to the internal cluster network
because
they don't have the same CNI. So it
means that webhooks, validating webhooks, mutating webhooks, or
whatever it is, it shouldn't work.
Now what I have to do is to
export again the kube config for the parent
cluster,
and I can issue kubectl
minus n, kube system logs minus f, cube
proxy,
and here comes the magic.
Nice.
So it means that our connection
is getting processed by the
Tenon control plane API server,
is going to be forwarded
to the Unix domain socket of connectivity agent
that is connected to the node where the
pod is running
and can interact with the local cubelet.
And with that said, it means that
we can retrieve logs.
We can install, obviously, our CRDs because in
the end we got our a different schema.
For example, now what I can do is
to say, m upgrade install capsule.
It's our shameless self promotion. Sorry for that,
Daniel. But I can install custom CRDs.
And these CRDs are interacting with
validation webhooks,
conversion webhooks. So it means that we are
ending up with
a lot of stuff, a lot of moving
stuff.
And in a matter of seconds, are ending
up with capture that has been installed properly.
So you're ending up with multi cluster management
made possible by Kamaji with the multi tenancy
inside that cluster
made possible by Capture.
We just need to wait.
But it should be okay.
Fingers crossed.
It was working. I think I tried that.
Everything has worked so far. It's not gonna
stop now. I think you're good.
Yeah. Come on, Cap. It's a it's a
matter of resources. I remember that. It's a
matter of resource. So
just to be sure,
captured system,
capture control manager,
limits because I'm not using so powerful machines.
That's the reason.
Bug in in production.
Okay.
Yeah. It has been solved. So Captual has
been installed. So custom resource definitions inside the
ad c d,
and everything is working.
Very cool.
And with that said, I think that
we finished our demo.
Well, how brave are you feeling? Because Yeah.
Yeah. Got an idea.
And that's all. So Do you wanna jump
back to your terminal?
Yeah. Absolutely. Absolutely.
Well,
our control plane here, can you run kubectl
get TCP?
So the kubectl control
plane.
You
in this pane,
I can do that.
Yes. So
that is Kubernetes
version one twenty three dot zero. Can we
upgrade that to one twenty four? Absolutely. Sure.
Sure.
So let me disconnect from here,
and let's go for watch minus n. Kube
CTL get panel control plane.
I'm going to edit panel control plane, Rawkode,
and let's search for the version.
Like a free one.
And as you can see here, we are
entering the upgrading state.
And in a matter of
waiting for
the images getting downloaded
and
placed in the in the notes,
we should ending up with the status upgraded
and so ready.
So it's just a matter of twelve seconds.
But, obviously, keep in mind that we just
upgraded
the control plane.
So you have to manage everything
on your own, like
cluster API,
Terraform,
Ansible, or whatever it is because we just
upgraded the control plane. And it's okay. I
mean, you upgrade the control plane and then
you upgrade the nodes.
There is no problem with the version skew
between worker nodes and control plane nodes.
Nice. I like that a lot.
And engine says he had that question too.
But engine does have one more question. He
was asking if we would be able to
add kilo to the mix, which is a
WireGuard based cross
multi cloud
component.
Kilo. I I don't know what is kilo.
Never heard about that.
Yeah. I I think it would work. I
mean, we don't need to dive into that
right now, but there's something to experiment with
another day. So Yeah. Yeah. Absolutely. Alright. Well,
that sorry. On you go, if if you
wanna
Yeah. Yeah. I was missing this slide. My
bad. Because I fucked up the order. So
we got also a roadmap for that because
we know that this project is pretty young.
It has been
open sourced
during the KubeCon in Europe,
in Valencia in 2022.
So it's really, really, really young.
And we are looking to get some benchmarking
and stress tests. So please
try to destroy Kamaji. We are looking for
that, and we are really happy for that.
But obviously, we know that we
have still a lot to do, especially with
that kubeadm is the right tool to manage
Kubernetes cluster integrations,
we would like to go in that path.
And if you think that's the not correct
one, please share that. We got the discussion
on GitHub
in the Kamaji repository.
Start discussion. We got also,
I forgot to say that, the channel hashtag
Kamaji in the Kubernetes Slack channel. So join
there so we can talk about that.
We will be really happy for that. But,
obviously, my demo was totally focused on the
click ops. So I connected to AWS. I
clicked the ear down, blah blah blah blah.
And, obviously, it's just for the demo because
having
everything automated will be absolutely great,
but you will miss all the moving pieces
behind that. So we are working with the
cluster API integration. We are working also with
the Terraform
because a lot of people wouldn't they don't
want to use cluster API because they are
managing Terraform for the whole infrastructure. And in
the end, the TerraControl plane is going to
be considered
as a component of the infrastructure.
And, honestly, also with cross plane.
But
since I got this heritage from cyber mobility
engineering,
I'm working also and I'm really happy. I
will be really happy also having had to
achieve that. We are working with the Prometheus
metrics because
we need to get monitoring and alerting. Obviously,
you can install
the metrics server in the time control plane,
but we would like to get also
overview
of all the clusters.
So getting know
how many clusters are performing the upgrade,
how many clusters, for example, they got
CA that is near the end of the
validity and so on and so forth. Or
eventually, how many tenant control planes have been
restarted
for any reason?
And last but not least,
it's
my it's really interesting, this one, is the
Kine integration.
Kine is a nice project. And if you
recall,
I told you all, if I will use
Kamaji production, I will never use Acd.
And someone will say,
starting raising an eyebrow, how can I use
Kubernetes without
etcd?
I need that. And that's true. But this
project that has been formally
developed by Ranger people
and right now is in process of getting
donated to the CMCF. It's in the
incubating or staging
phase, I don't remember. Anyway, with KINE, you
are using
an adapter.
So it means that there is adapter
that is,
how to say that, is is conformed, is
using the same signatures of the HCD.
So you got this endpoint,
and these HCD endpoints
are the same signature of a real HCD.
And you can use a driver
to say all the rights
shouldn't be forwarded
towards an etcd, but rather against a MySQL,
a PostgreSQL,
or eventually also SQLite
database.
Obviously,
I
will use
a database
as SQLite for production.
It really depends on this. You know so
with that said,
I truly believe that Kubernetes is great,
although sometimes I feel the pressure of the
complexity behind that.
But
operators
are saving our lives.
I mean,
with the operators,
we are removing the toil of managing complex
infrastructure.
Kubernetes itself is solving a lot of problems.
So if we can use an operator to
spawn multiple Kubernetes control planes,
And then
these control planes, obviously,
they need to scale out
because SSD got too many limitations.
The first one is regarding
its size.
You cannot exceed the eight gigabyte of storage.
Otherwise,
You know, I'm Italian. I use a lot
of Latin words.
So
It means that here comes the dragons. So
you don't know what could happen.
And I don't want to deal again
with split brain of etcd or unrecoverable
data from etcd. And with that said,
we are also working with kind integration.
We already have MySQL one. We are working
with the Postgres SQL one. And that's great
because
with the operators, there is a nice project
by EDB, EnterpriseDB,
that developed the CloudNetIPG.
So it's an operator that we are defining
a custom resource.
And from that custom resource, you're ending up
with the CA, with the certificates.
So it's just a matter of connecting all
the things together.
And with PostgreSQL
managed by Kubernetes itself that can auto scale,
your ending up of managing a Kubernetes cluster
at scale
like an hyperscaler, I'd say. I'm not saying
that Kamaji could replace AKS. Obviously, no. Neither
EKS.
But it could be used by your organizations,
also by your company when you are selling
or providing Kubernetes as a service to your
developers or other teams.
And I think that's really great because it's
the power of the open source.
So you don't need to rely on companies.
Obviously, they need to build. They need to
pay the salaries for all the software engineers
employed by AWS, Azure, and so on and
so forth. But you can do that on
your home, at home,
with a shared governance from the open source
community. And I think that's more interesting rather
than, okay, by
AWS or by Azure. End of the story.
I can say a word about the direction
of the project. I don't even know the
internals of AKS or EKS. With Kamaji instead,
you just need to issue the discussion.
With the discussion, we're starting
a discussion with the whole team members, with
all the community,
and we are just committed to deliver
our reliable software.
End of the story. So these are the
links, and I don't know. Maybe I talk
too much. My bad. No. No. I I
I love what you're saying, and it's all
useful context around what's going on here and
how cool this is. I think we have
one more question on the chat. What I'll
say is before I pass that question on,
if anyone else watching has any questions before
we finish up, please drop them into the
comment section now.
The question that we have is from engine.
Again, engine is asking, like, do you plan
on supporting other Kubernetes distribution? Could we use
Kamaji for KCS
or k zeros or etcetera?
Oh, that's a nice question, honestly.
We can think about that. Yeah, yeah. I
don't think there is any downside about that.
Keep in mind that we are just using
the
default images because in the end, if you
would like to use multiple clusters, you're ending
up using products by K3S,
by Muralantis, or K3S by Ranger, and so
on and so forth. So we just we
were trying to commit to the
vanilla
solution.
But, yeah, we can think about that. I
don't know. Maybe we are
but, yeah, k three s is CNCF compliant
CLASA. Yeah. So it's a compliance.
So I think that also the signature of
the CLI flags
are the same. So
open an issue, open a feature request. Let's
try to discuss that, and we can think
about that. Absolutely.
I will lie. I I will I will
love that. Yeah. Absolutely.
Very cool.
Alright. I don't think we have any more
questions. So with that, I will say, Dario,
thank you so much for taking time out
of your day and showing us Kamaji. It's
a really interesting project.
I'm really I I think it's something I'm
gonna have to experiment with on my bare
metal clusters and try and get more more
utilization of those control plane notes and bring
my own worker notes. So I'll definitely kick
the tires on it a bit more and,
open any issues, but I'm excited. I think
this is very, very cool.
Yeah. Thank you so much. Engine is saying,
I see Kamaji in the edge IoT context.
Feel free to share more on that. Like,
is that something you had considered?
Well, in the end, if you think about
that, I saw well, it's not my field,
honestly, because I've been a
web developer now playing with containers. So
the edge is really hard, also the bare
metal, to be honest.
But I remember that the great problem of
the edge is the fact that you're ending
up with a control plane on the edge.
You need a control plane on the edge
because otherwise, it's not like Docker's wall. Okay?
With Docker's wall, I remember that you were
ending up with multiple nodes that were acting
as control plane and also as workers, but
it was really
a bad pattern, I'd say,
because
you're mixing up the roles. So what happens
if an application is
killing the control plane components?
Instead, with Kamaji, in the end, you just
need, this sort of connection
with the control plane,
and you don't need to deploy the control
plane on the same edge location.
But, yeah, it's something that will be absolutely
interesting. To be honest, I'm missing the overall
picture of the edge because it's a different
word
word than me from my usual one. But,
yeah, I think so.
And if I'm wrong, tell me that. No
offense at all.
Alright.
Well, I think we'll leave that there. Thank
you again for joining me and for sharing.
I hope you have a wonderful day and
a wonderful weekend. To everyone watching, thank you
for your questions and for joining us today,
and we'll be back soon for more Rawkode
Live later.
Alright, Daniel. Have a good one. I'll see
you later on. Thanks. Bye.
Bye.